I definitely agree in that like there
should be no absolute thing any woman
should do there should not be an
absolute response to incest or rape or
any of these things every woman should
have the choice of if they want to or
not want to carry that child whether it
is
having fun getting raped incest whatever
it is it is I don't glorify and
glamorize abortion I think it's a very
traumatic thing I doubt that if somebody
wants has to do like if they have to do
it they'll do it I don't think that
people are like you know doing like half
six get the seventh free and having fun
with it and I think that like
glamorization and glorification of any
side is not okay